oh the tyranny of talk-radio our panel
is here to react radio host Cathy
Barnett Michael Knowles host of the
Michael Noel's show and political
science professor dr. Jeanne Zeena who
should have a radio show she's gonna
have one by the end of this segment guys
so so all of the liberal media and bob
Corker senator from tennessee is blaming
talk radio for this Kathy let's start
with you is it it is ridiculous we have
been wanting Americans have been wanting
this wall ever since the Reagan years
right but what we're seeing is a very
sustained trend among Democrats and
mainstream media if they don't like the
results of something then their answer
is to blame somebody blame someone
anybody everybody except for taking
personal responsibility for their own
failed policies and what we're
experiencing right now are Democrats
willing to move heaven and earth before
they fund the border wall before they do
the things that the American public is
asking for and trust me I get it right
because for many of these politicians
this is just business as usual this
isn't personal it's just politics but
what they don't seem to understand that
for many Americans myself included the
building of that southern border wall is
completely person so can you join with
the politicians shows you michael bob
Corker says that talk radio a completely
flipped trump century that's well this
is not about the tyranny of talk radio
this is about the tyranny of campaign
promises if bob Corker knew more about
keeping those perhaps he'd be returning
to the Senate this year president Trump
has done much better than his
predecessors on keeping his promise
that's what we are pointing out in talk
radio in podcast in the popular
political media is that this will be the
defining moment for the Trump presidency
can he keep his central campaign promise
thus far he has showed tremendous moral
clarity and political leadership on it
this is the last chance to do it the
majority of Americans want a wall they
want border security and President Trump
people we certainly we certainly here I
mean that's the pulse of talk radio and
representative of many Americans Jeanne
what do you say well you know I think
this is something repeatedly we see in
the modern presidency which is that if
you are a Democrat elected to the
presidency you are most vulnerable on
the left and if you are a Republican
elected to the presidency you are most
vulnerable
the right so of course the president to
Michael's point made a promise that he
now has to keep and he wants to make
sure his base knows that so that's what
we're seeing here but the real question
is not if talk radio is to blame or
who's to blame the real question here is
about sound policy what is the policy to
secure the border is it a wall is it the
Democrats other type of wall is it
something else effectiveness is what we
should be talking for a second though
here is speaker designate Nancy Pelosi
and what she sees as a moral issue when
it comes to the wall listen most of us
are speaking for myself consider the
wall immoral ineffective inexpensive we
have a responsibility all of us to
secure our borders north-south and
coming in by plane on our coast that's a
responsibility we honor but we do so by
honoring our values as well well yet
she's willing to pony up at least a
billionaire more for border fencing
Kathy now if you remember last year she
was saying that an effective border
security is to just is just to let our
grass grow tall but we have very real
issues I was looking at what ice put out
in their latest report showing that the
removal of illegal aliens are up 11% we
they removed over 1600 individuals to
homicide conviction over 3,700 with
sexual assault convictions not opinions
but convictions we have real problems we
have our own problems and we don't need
to import other people's problems into
our without a debt and we just had CBP
arrests of ms-13 more mister teen guys
Michael quickly I wanna get you guys to
weigh in what do you say well on the
democrat solution to the border wall I
wrote a blank book called reasons to
vote for Democrats I'm gonna write a
sequel called the Democrats solution to
the border crisis they've been talking
about it for years politicians of both
parties but when it actually comes time
to vote to fulfill that promise
they come up short because they're all
talk and they're no action and right now
is the moment it's put up or shut up do
or die and I'm very pleased that
President Trump is taking the leadership
on it and unfortunately for Democrats
they're gonna friend while we secure our
border all right I want to give you the
last word I think we should speak to the
experts who
say that technology personnel and
infrastructure are the three ways to the
secure the border right now they are
most in need of new 21st century
technology to secure that border that's
what we should be I'm not sure we've got
to go I'm not sure I totally agree with
the border patrol chiefs and they say
that infrastructure you got to have all
three in the information technology to
support that infrastructure you do but
again I've got to run this but you know
he's putting his opinion out there based
on what these Chiefs say thanks very
much guys
Kathy Michael dr. zeno merry Christmas
to you